first up measure out your dry  ingredients plain flour wholemeal flour  salt caster sugar and bicarbonate soda  mix get 450 Miller buttermilk or most of  it in and combined buttermilk has a  wonderful subtle sour note that gives  this bread a deliciously different taste  you can get it in most other big  supermarkets if your dough is a bit  stiff add the rest of your buttermilk  flour your board gently knead the  mixture for about 30 seconds until it's  all combined dust your baking tray place  your dough in the center and score a  deep crust with a knife to get a perfect  crust then simply bake in a preheated  oven for 30 to 35 minutes amazingly easy  absolutely delicious and foolproof hot  crusty homemade soda bread whenever you  want bring the heat up into the pan a  nice little knob of butter mix Dijon  mustard white wine vinegar  Olive Oyl and saffron